ça y est le père noël est passé ici à la
verrière les cartons débordent de
poupées voitures et autres joueuses en
tout genre tous sont étiquetés entre 1
et 10 euros
de quoi offrir aux enfants des familles
en difficulté un vrai noël ce sont des
jouets que nous collectons à la fois
auprès de particuliers des dons toute
l'année en collecte et il ya eu aussi
une grande partie des jouets qui
viennent de la collègue de ski bus avant
de les mettre en vente le secours
populaire tri vérifie et si besoin
reparler jouer bien que les collectes
souhaite effectuer tout au long de
l'année
la braderie propose toutefois des jouets
dernière mode à prix cassés quand vous
voyez qu'il ya des jouets qui sont
vendus à 5 euros alors qu'ils valent 30
ou 40 donc c'est quand même intéressant
pour tous ces gens qui sont en grande
difficulté
en une matinée la braderie a vendu pour
600 euros de jouets une somme qui
servira notamment à financer le repas du
nouvel an du secours populaire organisée
sur des péniches à paris et si vous vous
demandez encore pourquoi les père noël
sont verts voilà la réponse au début des
années 1900 le père noël était vert et
le père noël rouge il est devenu rouge
grâce à une grande société qui s'appelle
coca cola un pied de nez à une société
de consommation qui a bien inventé le
père noël rouge mais oublié de faire
profiter tous les enfants de sa
générosité